I was kind of wondering how long it
would be before I could say this again
if I'd ever say it again
but OnePlus is kind of back
so this is the new OnePlus 11. now
people who have been following the
industry for a little bit already know
the story behind this phone which is
OnePlus starting out hot as a fan
favorite with a plus bang for the buck
Flagship killer type of phones peaking
I'd say around the OnePlus 7 Pro it's my
phone of the year and then slowly
descending into the very generic
expensive Flagship that they swore to
kill their last attempt at a phone the
10t is literally the worst phone that
came out last year it won my bust of the
year and I got a trophy for it and
apparently they've used this as
motivation they keep saying oh they now
they want to redeem themselves now
they're gonna turn it around and you
know great like I think we all know the
next phone was already in the works by
the time they got that trophy but if you
want to give me some credit I'll take
some credit sure but the point is
they're sort of reflecting shades of old
OnePlus which is a really good thing
because this phone is
really good so this is a flagship
smartphone right now for 6.99 in a world
where the Galaxy s23 just came out it's
7.99 that's a sort of a de facto default
for a lot of people my semi-hot take is
this could be a better phone for a lot
of people now it's not perfect and they
still do some classic Corner cutting
things to pull this off and there are
still some software behaviors that I
really do not like but here are the
basics so if you want just a classic
spec sheet bang for the buck summary
this phone has a Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 with
8 gigs of RAM a 6.7 inch 1440p 120 hertz
OLED display triple cameras and a 5 000
milliamp hour battery with 80 watt
charging for 699 bucks that's pretty
damn good so I think because the phone
has like the nice screen the big battery
and the newest chip it begs comparisons
to like the 900 000 other Flagship
phones but like I said it does cut some
Corners the big one being no wireless
charging huge and then the other it's
ip64 rated instead of IP67 so it'll
survive a Mist better than a splash but
on the design front I'd call this a
mixed bag mixed bag you know it
definitely is taking a step away from
the ultra generic last generation the
Hasselblad branding is back and we'll
talk about the cameras in a minute but
also the alert slider is back literally
an iconic OnePlus feature that they
somehow thought getting rid of last time
was a good idea this one also has a very
slightly textured matte black finish on
the back not quite Sandstone level but
enough to be interesting so I like it
and the camera bump the camera bump is
kind of a weird hybrid of smoothly
wrapping around the side like Samsung
used to but then turning it into a big
circle Plateau that looks like a generic
not seamless thing anymore at all it's
whatever I don't mind it it's fine but
you're not here for the back of the
phone though like honestly if you just
saw the back and saw the lack of
wireless charging and a slightly awkward
camera bump it feels like a 699 phone
sure but the front is where it gets way
more impressive 6.7 inch corner to
corner thin bezel with a slight curve
over the edges I wish it was flatter but
it's not too bad 1440p resolution 120
hertz ltpo OLED 1000 Hertz touch sample
rate and 1300 nits Peak brightness
that's visible outdoors in all but
direct sunlight and that little corner
cut out for the selfie camera that's
nearly as good as you can ask for these
days and actually using a phone it's
very Snappy and smooth it's got the
fingerprint reader on the display in
just the right spot it's fast and
OnePlus One a little over the top with
like the future proofing of the highest
end fastest internals it's good details
like this phone has not just Wi-Fi 6 or
Wi-Fi 6E but the brand new Wi-Fi 7 not
just UF S3 but ufs 4.0 the fastest
storage and not just LP ddr5 but LP
ddr5x the fastest memory available so
this is legitimately very Snappy and
it's a quick phone brand new but then
because of those high-end internals I do
expect the Headroom to age pretty well
the snap Dragon Age Gen 2 has proven to
be a pretty good chip like the other
phones that have had it so far have been
really good phones and this is too it's
a powerful chip and the GPU is great but
also it's been pretty efficient and
that's affecting the battery situation
and I think for battery on this phone
this is where it feels the most like old
OnePlus so the OnePlus 11 has a 5 000
milliamp hour battery
great battery life so if I if I use it
like normal maxed out High brightness
1440p and 120 hertz on I'm making it to
the end of the day fine no problem when
I go 1080P and still 120 hertz I was
able to get two days out of this phone
matter of fact I'm on the second day
right now it's almost noon I have 31
percent that's pretty good I'm getting
to the end of two light days with like
seven eight hours of screen on time fine
that's really good and then for charging
in the US this one has 80 watt charging
I think in China other versions have 100
watt charging there's a difference in
electrical standards but super fast
charging so if I ever found myself
thinking oh I need a little extra
battery it's kind of low right now it
was rare but I could plug in for a few
minutes and have more than enough it is
that Oppo supervook charging Tech so
it's still the brick with USB a instead
of USBC but hey at least it comes in the
Box plus the cable so I know also having
wireless charging would be really
convenient and it's kind of annoying
going from a phone that does have
wireless charging to one that doesn't
but I think OnePlus is counting on
people who have other phones now that
don't have wireless charging moving to
this one and finding it's like an
awesome battery experience so that's
what they're counting on but let me talk
about the cameras in this phone because
these are also a throwback to Old
OnePlus which if you remember those
phones means
not as good as the flagships but really
solid so it's got that 50 megapixel main
camera that bins down to 12 and a half
megapixels and it gives me images that
are generally pretty sharp and nice if
you don't zoom in I mean I was
pleasantly surprised that in most
different types of shooting scenarios it
was at least capable of giving me a
solid shot even in low light when it
does miss it tends to overexpose a bit
and even more so with darker skin tones
also focus is a little suspiciously slow
sometimes so I found myself taking
multiple shots of moving objects just to
make sure I got a good one but you know
what if the bar is being set at just a
good enough camera that it's not a dead
giveaway that it's a cheaper phone it
clears that bar for sure I couldn't tell
you how much that Hasselblad partnership
is actually doing for photos here I mean
color science maybe it seems like
there's pretty balanced colors and nice
Optical characteristics but like that's
about all I can say about that I mean
the photos look fine the ultrawide is
definitely soft near the edges of the
frame but at least it matches colors
pretty well with the main and it does do
macro when you get super up close to
things
but it's not good macro I mean it does
the macro but yeah not great the only
reason I'm not going to keep dailying
this phone though aside from other
phones that I have to test very soon is
the software there's just some things
that I I mean the software is fine lots
of people use this software all over the
world I have no problem with it there's
so many little quirks and things that
they just add up and they get annoying
so here if you're going to be like old
OnePlus One Plus let's have some
feedback let's listen to some user
feedback here so I'm an Android User who
spends a lot of time in the
notifications it's very important part
of the phone a lot of other people spend
a lot of time there too
in every other Android phone that I've
used when you have a notification you
can swipe left or swipe right to clear
them but for some reason on this phone
you can only swipe away to the right if
you swipe to the left no matter how fast
your swipe is it pulls up settings and
then you have to swipe again to clear so
this is slightly annoying every single
time and then in every other Android
phone if I have multiple notifications
from the same app then I can swipe down
with one or two fingers to view each one
and if I just want to open the app you
click it or if you want to open a
specific instance of that notification
you can do that when it's expanded on
this phone for some reason you can't
swipe to expand the group of
notifications you can only click it
which expands it but then in the apps
where there's a single notification and
you want to expand it like a camera
preview or a message preview or
something with more information you
can't just swipe like every other
Android phone you have to tap this tiny
bar at the top of the notification
around that Arrow to view the preview
that is even more annoying over time and
then in every other Android phone if you
pull down your notifications and you
have a lot of them you can always go you
know what never mind and then pull them
all the way back up to close on this
phone it takes multiple swipes to get
through all your notifications and close
them every time that's a little more
annoying and then if you have music
playing in the background say on Spotify
or podcast or something you want to get
to that app on every other phone it's a
swipe and a Tap Away on this phone it's
a swipe a tap and another tap to get to
the app there's a bunch of little things
like that from coming from almost any
other Android phone that doesn't use
color Os or this version of software and
it would be fine if that's the default
Behavior but there's at least a toggle
to let me not have that happen every
time but it happens every time but the
good thing is other than that there's a
lot of nice things like in this software
it's very well thought out and laid out
I think especially with the haptics and
the combination of visual and haptic
touches throughout it like pulling up
and down the brightness slider you get
this nice haptic feed feedback or going
up and down in volume it's the same
thing it very well thought out in that
way so I think if OnePlus really wants
to sort of redeem themselves and they
look back a little bit at what was so
successful with oxygen OS I know they
eventually did this merge thing with
Oppo and color OS but look at what
people loved about oxygen OS and really
think about bringing some of those
things back okay so this one's
competition at 6.99 it's kind of
interesting I think today you'd probably
consider buying a pixel 7 for 5.99 but
what this phone will have over some of
these other phones in this price range
is some of the highest end specs the
Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 and the 1440p display
specifically it'll always have some of
those spec things if you're interested
in that there's even a 799 version that
has 16 gigs of RAM and 256 gigs of
storage too so yeah that's that's what
feels like sort of classic Redemption
OnePlus is this a full Redemption no I'm
not going to give them full Redemption
status yet uh but if the if the
character Arc of OnePlus was kind of
like this and then like like this
it does feel like this is a inflection
point it feels like this is a little bit
of a shift in the right direction at
least so now I just hope they keep it
going you know if they might be past
their Peak but their performance and
price of this phone show potential
thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace
[Music]